tonight on the new reality
what's the question you get asked most
frequently when is it going to arrive
can we see it distributing the covet
vaccine will be a relay race
when that first vaccine arrives we want
to be ready to move it each piece of
this supply chain
is part of an intricate jigsaw puzzle
how big
of an undertaking is this this is
massive
i didn't really feel like human you make
money so that you can
live but i wasn't making enough money to
live basic income and policies have the
potential
to improve health outcomes i think if
there's any country that can do this
we have a chance to lead something on a
world stage
hello i'm donna friesen everyone calls
it the light at the end of the tunnel
a vaccine for covid19 is coming the
scientists have done the work in record
time and
health canada is expected to approve the
first one possibly as soon as
mid-december
that will trigger the most ambitious and
complex vaccine program
ever attempted the pressure to deliver
and to do it fast
is intense carolyn jarvis takes us
through how the vaccine rollout will
happen
starting at a manufacturing facility in
switzerland and the canadian
in charge
below the towering swiss alps the
unassuming town of visp
home to a mere 8 000 people is making
what could be
the vaccine the world is waiting for
the recipe is moderna's a pharmaceutical
company based in the u.s
that quickly realized during a pandemic
that to meet global demand
it would need a manufacturing partner
and a secondary production plant in
europe
it found both with the firm lonza based
in switzerland if modernist covet 19
vaccine is approved for use
this is where the canadian supply will
come from
and the man in charge of the operation
nicolas charney
is canadian himself what's the question
you get asked most frequently
when is it going to arrive when can we
see it
for canadians the answer is early 2021.
so you're already producing the vaccine
yes
canada is one of the countries that move
very very fast in securing
vaccines with us it's one of the first
countries or
one of the top countries to to receive
our supply also
because canada doesn't have the
manufacturing capacity at home
it's relying on international partners
like moderna to receive its vaccine
construction on moderna's four
production lines in visp
is still ongoing but it's expected this
site will produce
upwards of 300 million doses by the end
of 2021
and when combined with its manufacturing
plant in the us
modernist says it could make as many as
a billion doses
next year what does your family back in
sherbrooke say hey
they're all behind us they're telling me
hey how how fast can we get this
because we want to see you we want you
to travel and come and see us again
and we haven't seen our family for for
almost a year now
modernist vaccine which it says is 94
effective
is in health canada's hands now
undergoing review
if it is approved for use it will be
sent to spain
to be put into vials then shipped to
canada when that first vaccine arrives
we want to be ready to move it
general rick hillier who led nato forces
in afghanistan
was recently tapped to lead the vaccine
rollout for ontario
when you got the call what was your
first reaction i'm really not looking
for a job
i thought about a word which is right on
the new afghan
memorial right here says duty duty calls
and when your premier phones and says
can you help you can't say no
duty calls so what will your days look
like well long
and intense hillier will be directing a
team through a logistical labyrinth
coordinating shipping storage and
perhaps most crucially
tracking who gets the vaccine and when
they're due back for a second dose
we're talking to the i t professionals
they're talking about
building a system that is already in
progress
on ipads to use at those sites to log
where the vaccines are
where they're going to connect that to
health cards to make sure
that we have a record that somebody has
been vaccinated making sure patients
return for that second dose
is what worries dr michael finkelstein
of toronto public health
the most we have a lot of experience
with people getting vaccines
but much less experience with people
needing two doses
and so it's going to be very important
for us to be able to
remind people and making sure that they
get the message they have to come back
it will be up to each province to decide
if the vaccine is administered in public
health clinics
hospitals your doctor's office or
pharmacies
and up to each one to have an i.t system
in place to track that
daniel chiasson is the president of the
canadian association for pharmacy
distribution management
if we're going to be using pharmacies
they already have
that capacity in place so no if you get
medication
and your medication expires in 30 days
they'll they'll provide you with the
recall
to say you're you're due you know how
would that actually play out do they
call you do they email you
it could be all of them all of the above
so then the question is
can we actually bridge all the it
systems from the various pharmacies
or the pharmacy chains and move it up to
the provincial level if they want to
actually have full visibility and
transparency can you do that
you can yes and we do that with the flu
vaccine today
distributing the covet vaccine will be a
relay race
good afternoon and the final stretch
says chief matthew pegg
head of toronto's immunization task
force will fall to cities
how big of an undertaking is this
this is massive typically when chief
pegg directs an emergency response
it's done here at the city's emergency
operations center
this is him in march mere days before
ontario declared a state of emergency
it's important that we have people here
it's important that
we bring people together now pegg
directs a team of hundreds
virtually it's a different way to work
we've all had to pivot we've all had to
pivot very quickly
i'd love to know what the big dots are
on your to-do list
right now the biggest hurdle or biggest
check box from a logistics standpoint is
identifying all of the facilities that
we're going to require
where people will ultimately be able to
come to get vaccinated
so you may have to set up clinics
meaning you might have to have a space
where people could come much like your
testing facilities right now we're
assuming that that's a guarantee that we
will have to do that
and then of course it will be making
sure that we're able to
to identify those and set those up in
strategically located around the city so
that they're they're
reasonably accessible by all of our
residents that there's you know good
networks to get people there and back
chief peg is also looking for facilities
to serve as warehouses
for the mountain of inventory that just
this week started landing on his
doorstep
to avoid what happened in the spring
when canada was forced to fight for
personal protective equipment
the federal government has signed
contracts with medical supply companies
back in dickinson for 90 million
syringes and 100 million needles
and cardinal health for 90 million
alcohol swabs
75 million bandages and gauze strips
what's the hardest part of this for your
team dealing with the volume is going to
be
a critical element that is going to put
stress on the system
the how much and when are still unknowns
canada has signed contracts with eight
different vaccine makers
which could provide more than 400
million doses
on different timelines and each one may
have its own constraints
like pfizers one of the other leading
candidates
which has to be stored at minus 70
degrees celsius
requiring an infrastructure some have
warned canada
is not yet equipped to handle the
bottleneck for me
is at the warehouse level do we actually
have sufficient capacity
with the right equipment in terms of
refrigeration
or frozen capacity to do it the
infrastructure exists
today do we have enough of it the
federal government has ordered 26
ultra-cold freezers required for
pfizer's vaccine
and another 100 laboratory freezers
needed for modernis
one of those contracts worth 1.1 million
dollars was signed with thermo fisher
scientific
out of north carolina dr alex esmen is
its general manager of cold storage
criticality of this is huge being able
to manage the temperature from the point
of manufacturing through distribution
and ultimately
to preparation for injection it just
can't be overstated
laurel wiseman is the president of esby
scientific
a distribution company out of markham
ontario that's
also been contracted by the feds to
secure freezers
so we actually have stock already here
that we've sent out
to the feds to i think ontario's going
out today
alberta has gone out right across the
country
to help with the cold constraints pfizer
will ship its vaccine directly from its
manufacturing plants
to 14 sites across canada a number the
federal government says will eventually
grow to 205 sites
pfizer's vials will be put in specially
designed packages using dry ice
and equipped with gps thermal sensors
tracking the temperature of the vaccine
as it travels on the receiving end
canada is readying the dry ice he put
out a contract for 20 000 kilograms of
it
to be delivered to a hundred locations
across the country
every week each piece of this supply
chain
is part of an intricate jigsaw puzzle
daunting
daunting has become a very common word
come
january if both the moderna and pfizer
vaccines are approved
the first wave of what's expected to be
six million doses
should start arriving so when the
province says to all right chief peg the
vaccine is here you're going to say
my commitment is to say okay we're ready
to go
but until then there is one more hurdle
fatigue we're tired i'm tired
and our team is tired at the front line
the days start early and go long into
the night
when you're on mission for 6 or 9 or 12
months the most dangerous time
for the soldiers is the first month and
the last month
but from the canadian in switzerland
manufacturing what could be the answer
there is finally reason to smile of
course there's tremendous pressure but
there's
there's also a tremendous motivation
i can't wait for the day where there are
vaccines out there and there's
there's a solution for this this
pandemic it's impacting everybody
but on your end it's coming yes yes it's
coming yeah
coming up on the new reality i think we
need to be bold now we cannot wait
proponents say politicians have to stop
looking at guaranteed income
as an expenditure we're investing in the
kind of society we want to build
we're investing in opportunities for our
children and for our grandchildren
welcome back imagine a world where every
adult gets a set amount of money from
the government
on a regular basis it's not tied to work
or education levels
it's just a basic income the idea has
been floating around for years as a way
to alleviate poverty and give every
citizen a financial cushion
lots of countries have studied it some
have run small pilot projects
but it's so expensive no country has
adopted it
now the pandemic has breathed new life
into those advocating for a universal
basic income
michael couture explores what it is and
whether it will ever
fly a casual stroll with her camera in
tow was once a luxury jessie gollum
couldn't afford three years ago she was
stuck
in four dead-end jobs working upwards of
80 hours a week and it still wasn't
enough
i didn't really feel like human when i
was doing those jobs because like
you make money so that you can live and
i was
but i wasn't making enough money to live
her dream of running her own photography
business seemed to be slipping away
and she struggled just to survive but
then
the ontario government started a basic
income pilot project that provided
around seventeen thousand dollars a year
to four thousand residents living on low
income
enough to cover basic needs like rent
and food
golem applied and was accepted i
remember thinking to myself i just
thought
huh my rent is covered my rent is
covered
my rent is covered and i just started
sobbing in my car as i was driving home
because i could just feel this like
weight of relief just lift off of me
the stability of basic income allowed
her to launch her business
and it was working i was actually
finding that i was making more money
than i was before when i was cobbling
together those jobs and
stressed and depressed but only after
one year
in 2018 the newly elected progressive
conservative government
scrapped the project claiming it was a
failure
golem was devastated dozens of other
recipients felt the same way
they protested outside the ontario
legislature
golum asked fellow former basic income
recipients to write out
how the program changed their lives
there's roland
you said he struggled with addiction and
homelessness
but basic income helped him get out of
poverty and then
he went to school and got into a trade
and basic income
like gave her just just a little bit of
leeway a little bit of freedom and a
little bit of like
just made it easier to be able to
support her child and raise her child
gollum and her portrait series called
humans of basic income
started touring around ontario then
canada
and then she was invited to travel
overseas to talk about the project and
how ending it
was devastating i also watched a
physical transformation
of these people falling back into
poverty
and that was and still is to this very
day
very very difficult to see and then the
pandemic hit
this is why basic income is getting so
much attention now
millions of canadians lost their jobs
and the kennedy emergency response
benefit or serb
has been a lifeline and showed what was
possible
and despite the serb racialized and
disadvantaged communities have been
impacted especially hard
the pandemic exposing the inequities
that already
existed it goes without saying that
living in poverty
is very expensive dr nahid dasani is a
palliative care physician who
specializes
in caring for homeless and vulnerable
populations
i do think that basic income and
policies
associated with it have the potential to
improve health outcomes but also reduce
health care utilization like a stay in a
hospital
or a visit to an emergency department
for a fuller picture of what basic
income could do
you have to head a little west and back
in time nearly 40 years
in 1974 the small town of dauphin
manitoba became the test case for
something dubbed
mincom researchers wanted to see if
people stopped working
after you gave them a basic income the
model was simple
people qualified if they made under a
certain amount of money
for example a family of four was
eligible
if their total income was under thirty
eight hundred dollars a year or
just over nineteen thousand in twenty
twenty dollars
health economist evelyn farget studied
the program data and found those who
were employed
stayed employed only two groups stopped
working
mothers who extended their paltry
maternity leave
and young men those teens didn't just
collect the cash and do nothing
forget says it bought them the ability
to continue their education
well if you think about the differences
in opportunities that are available
for somebody who finished grade 12 in
1975 for example as opposed to somebody
who left high school at age 16 and got
an immediate job you can imagine the
different
life path they would follow over the
next 40 years advocates believe the
candidate emergency response benefit or
serb is a big reason why
basic income is finding traction now
serb paid out
81.6 billion dollars and helped nearly
9 million canadians but that benefit is
not available to all those who need it
basic income would be the parliamentary
budget officer has pegged the cost of a
basic income scheme
at anywhere between 47 and 98
billion dollars over six months
opponents insist it's too expensive
and the return on investment is just not
there
what do you say to people who believe
that a guaranteed income or a basic
income
will just see more people sit at home
and do nothing and collect that money
my first answer is that there is
absolutely no evidence of that
in any of the pilots and any of the
programs that we've run
sheila regier heads up the basic income
canada network one of many groups that's
been promoting the idea for decades
she sees the pandemic as the perfect
time to push
for basic income again people want to do
better
and all of the pilots verify that
proponents say
politicians have to stop looking at
guaranteed income
as an expenditure and more like an
investment
we're investing in the kind of society
we want to build we're investing in
opportunities for our children and for
our grandchildren
and we're looking for returns on that
investment over the longer run
and i think it's very hard for somebody
who's looking to
fight an election in two years or three
years or four years to make those kinds
of long-term
decisions but those are the kinds of
decisions we have to make i think as a
society
measuring societal success can be
difficult but in the manitoba income
project
hospital use decreased by 8.5 percent
which suggests health care savings
across the country
could be significant in the more recent
ontario project mcmaster university
researchers found an
overwhelming majority of participants
reported their health was somewhat or
much
better than before basic income
political will
and potential costs have prevented a
livable income from becoming a
countrywide reality but this time there
is
a cross-party effort to push ahead so we
held our own town hall with three mps
from different parts of the country
all with the same goal by show of hands
who wants some form of livable or basic
income to be put into place for
canadians i put two hands up
oh yes yes jennica atwin is the green mp
for fredericton leah gazan is the ndp mp
for winnipeg center
and naderskin smith is the liberal mp
for toronto beaches east york
i think we need to be bold now we cannot
wait we cannot wait for our suicide
rates to continue to increase
we cannot wait for the disabled
community to continue to sound the alarm
that they're consistently forgotten
forgotten about
it needs to be in addition to a current
and future uh government
uh programs and supports things like
um you know medicare affordable
accessible social housing we need
investments and nader skin smith
is leading a movement within the liberal
caucus to make basic income
a top priority let's do what we can over
the coming six months
as the crb is still in place to develop
plans to address
income and wealth inequality erskine
smith points out basic income programs
already exist
in two forms seniors with the guaranteed
income supplement
and old age security pension the canada
child benefit
is also there for families but he admits
there is a missing middle
of working canadians who have been left
behind
seeing the cross partisan political will
gives jessie gollum hope
something she didn't have much of a few
years ago
and she has a message for prime minister
justin trudeau
as he guides canada out of the pandemic
i think if there's any country that can
do this like we have a chance to
not only build a better world and lead
an economic revolution we have a chance
to lead something on a world
stage
next week on the new reality the impact
of covet 19 on the brain
could be conceived of us accelerating
brain aging
i didn't know who i was where i was i
don't know how long i was like that i
just remember coming out of it and still
feeling really really confused running a
bath is a treacherous thing to do now
because
i have to sit there and watch it because
i don't know if i leave the room if i'm
going to remember that that's what i was
doing
the virus might impact the brain in
certain people impairing their
activities of daily living so this is a
healthcare issue and a societal issue
[Music]
that is the new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen
thanks for watching
you